Hi, I'm Steven Jarvis and I'm comester with Pac-46 in Fayetteville, Arkansas.
This edition of the Scout Mentor Podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now it's the old Scout Master.
You know I was going over how to read a topographic map
and I pointed out lots of things on the map. you know mountains and valleys and a plateau.
I said, well, you know, this is a plateau,
And one of my scouts wanted to know exactly what a plateau was.
So I told him that it's the highest form of flattery.
Oh, come on now. that's a real beaut, isn't it?
Oh, my well, this is podcast number 212..
Welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look in the mailbag and see what we've got waiting for us here.
Awesome show, said Z-Bug over on iTunes, who left a five-star review for us.
Thank you, Clark, for the great podcast.
I look forward to it every week. the show's professional
And to the point. it's helping me guide our scouts.
Thank you again.
Hey, thanks so much for that lovely review.
I really do appreciate it.
James Kangus got in touch with us via LinkedIn.
He said: just dropping you a note. I discovered the Scout Circle webcast
and watched the entire hour with Enoch Hysie.
I look forward to watching the previous Scout Circle videos
and look forward to the new ones.
Thanks, James.
I'm glad you enjoyed the Scout Circle that we did with Enoch last month.
If you haven't checked that out, folks go right to ScoutMasterCGcom.
follow the Scout Circle link and you'll find all the Scout Circle webcasts
that we've recorded over the past year.
Jeff Cavistad is the Scout Master with Troop 965 in Kuwait City, Kuwait.
You'll remember an interview we did with Jeff back last year on one of our podcasts
And he wrote in to say: I finally became a backer
and I'm happy to join this August Circle.
I continue to listen to your podcasts on the way to work here in warm, sunny Kuwait.
We do know how much snow and cold you have experienced this winter.
Well, thanks, Jeff. I think
My family and I are moving back to the States on June 1st,
so I only have a few months left as Scout Master of Troop 965 here in Kuwait.
Take care,
I'll keep on listening.
Well, thanks so much, Jeff.
It's good to hear from you and thank you so much for becoming a backer.
I'm going to tell everybody else how they can do that in just a moment.
We heard from Steve Cattrell and he's with Cub Scout Pack 3623 in Shepherd, Michigan.
And Steve wrote in to say I really enjoyed your conversation with Bess Elwell Cook
in podcast 210..
I've told my Girl Scout leader wife that she should listen to it.
Many of the things Bess mentioned about Girl Guides in Australia
are very similar to what happens here in the Girl Scouts.
Thanks again for all your hard work.
Well, thanks for listening, Steve.
Just goes to show that scouting is the same no matter where you are,
And that's one of the greatest things about it, isn't it?
Jerry Fish wrote in to say: great info on the podcast.
I've got a leadership training session soon
and I want to play the song My Favorite Boy Scout.
Can you tell me where I can find that?
And at the same time I'll tell everybody else: go to scoutmastercgcom
and look for the post that contains podcast 212,
and I'll have a link to where you can get that song.
So this week over at scoutmastercgcom,
on Wednesday, March 12th, from 7 to 8 pm,
Enoch Hysie is going to be online
for a live Green Bar Life Chat.
As you've heard several times in the past,
Enoch is the author of our Green Bar Life Articles
at ScoutmasterCG
And he's going to make himself available for that hour
to chat with Scouts about youth leadership.
That's going to be Wednesday.
this Wednesday, March 12th, from 7 to 8 pm.
You heard earlier about becoming a backer,
and it's pretty simple.
If you're a regular reader or listener
and you're finding what we offer has helped you,
you can help us keep things up and running
by becoming a scoutmastercgcom backer.
Funds from backers go towards the expenses
of producing and publishing the blog posts
and the podcasts and all the other resources
and keeping them freely accessible
to scouts all over the world.
And I want to make sure to thank Jeff Kvistad
and Kevin Yandell, who both signed on as backers this week.
Thank you so much for helping us keep things going here.
Over the past couple of weeks
we've had a couple of interviews
as major parts of the podcast,
And that means that the email questions
have been piling up.
So in this podcast
we're going to answer a big pile of email questions
And that's going to take up the remainder of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
He's my favorite all-time boy scout.
You're my favorite all-time boy scout.
You were always on the beat boy, beat boy.
I'll hang it in the street boy, street boy.
We were dancing to the beat boy, beat boy.
You're my favorite all-time boy scout.
He's my favorite all-time boy scout.
Write me a letter, send it by name
Email. that is folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
Brock Ford is the Scoutmaster Boy Scout Troop 53
in Maytown, Pennsylvania.
He wrote in to say
I discovered your podcast and blog about three months ago
after I was approached to become a Scoutmaster.
Last night was my first official meeting as Scoutmaster
and it was a train wreck.
The troop of 20 scouts are essentially acting as one big patrol
and they didn't have much planned for last night.
To make things more difficult, a new scout just crossed over
and dad was displeased by the disorganization and horse play
at his son's first scout meeting.
We've discussed really implementing the patrol method
and our patrol leaders council has agreed.
Last night, the youth leaders worked on deciding how to reorganize patrols.
I realized that this is a long process
and that the scouts need lots of guidance,
since I don't think most of them would have any idea
of what it means to be a patrol leader,
I have a few questions for you.
We have a court of honor coming up
and we want the scouts to lead most of it,
so I was wondering if you have any ideas
or a template for a simple court of honor.
Traditionally, we've saved all the rank and merit badge patches
until the court of honor, but when I asked about this,
I sense everyone is agreeable to giving the award out
as soon as possible and recognizing it again at the court of honor.
Do you usually have youth give out all the patches
at the court of honor, or do scout masters usually give out things?
I also wanted to ask about how you handle
your scout master minute.
We haven't had one as a part of our troop meetings
and I'm wondering best how to get this started.
We usually do lots of announcements
at the end of the meeting
and I know the scouts get tired of this
because it takes a long time.
so the scout master would be humorous
or inspirational or mix it up
Well. Brock, first of all,
thanks for getting in touch
and congratulations on becoming a scout master.
I want you to zoom out a little bit
because, as a new scout master,
you're going to have a million details on your plate.
so instead of focusing on those details,
let's zoom out and look at the whole picture.
From that perspective
you'll begin to learn what's really important
and you'll get those things right
and many of the details will take care of themselves.
Disorganized, difficult kind of chaotic meetings
are nothing that I want you to aim at trying to fix,
no matter how many parents grumble about them,
and I don't want you to aim at fixing the meetings,
because they're going to fix themselves
as you empower and train your youth leaders.
I've been doing this for 30 years now
and I've got to tell you most of our troop meetings
would be regarded as chaotic
and disorganized to any casual observer.
Learn to look
for promising moments and initiatives.
you'll see in your youth leaders,
and these will appear to be very small
and insignificant at first-
and build on these with a whole lot of praise and effort.
You're correct in saying that this is a long process,
and that's true, because it never stops.
It never arrives at completion.
You'll never reach a point where you have
totally arrived at anything resembling perfection.
The nature of our work as Scoutmasters
is building skills and competency in youth leadership.
As soon as they become competent in one area,
they move on to new challenges.
You'll always be developing,
but you'll never be finished.
It's not just a long process,
it is an infinitely long process.
so your measured and responsive guidance
to the initiative you see
in your youth leaders is important,
but it's easy to go way too far.
A new patrol leader needs to learn
what to do in the next hour,
not what he needs to do in the next year.
I will tell you from my experience:
adults tend to over instruct
and their guidance becomes interference.
if we're not cautious,
You won't ever have a cadre of
wholly competent, fully functioning patrol leaders.
but, handled the right way,
You'll have a lot of energized,
engaged Scouts learning
some very important things.
As for the Court of Honor,
it's not about getting things right or wrong.
it's about understanding the principles behind
why we have something called the Court of Honor.
If you haven't already
get a copy of the Guide to Advancement 2013
and read about Courts of Honor and Recognition,
The directions and answers there
are better than any I'm going to be able to give you
and then, taking those principles,
apply them to the Court of Honor
you're about to have.
One of the things you'll learn
when you read the Guide to Advancement 2013
is that we want Scouts
to be recognized for their achievements
as soon as possible.
So, yes, we present them with the badge
as soon as we have it
and we hold on to the certificate
that comes with the badge
to present at the Court of Honor.
As for the Scout Master Minute,
that's the only adult
who has a speaking role
at troop meetings.
And, yes, you can mix it up,
it can be humorous,
it can be inspiring,
but it needs to be right there at a minute,
and a minute is 60 seconds long.
so I find that I need to practice sometimes,
otherwise I'll just keep going
on and on and on. and Scouts,
they don't have time for that, do they?
I would tell the other adults in your troop:
if they have something to announce,
they can write it down
and you or the senior patrol leader
will take care of making the announcement
at the end of the meeting.
Not everybody is going to like this at first,
but stand firm.
If you have this big, unfettered,
open-ended announcements time
at the end of a Scout Meeting,
people are going to find things to say
and they're going to take a lot of time
saying that
If you go by the principle that
the Scout Master has the only adult
speaking role at a troop meeting.
you know, just as a rule of thumb,
people will begin to get on board,
get them to write those things down
and then, in my opinion,
you really want the senior patrol leader
making those announcements.
So around here we call
becoming a Scout Master
jumping into the volcano.
It's a little overwhelming at first,
but don't worry. as you get some experience
and observe what is going on with your Scouts,
you'll gain confidence in your judgment
of what's important and what isn't.
Take all the time you can
to study and learn about your role
and put that knowledge to work.
If your heart's in the right place,
it's not likely you're going to do any harm.
What you'll do is a lot of good.
Vin Cervantes is in Massachusetts
and he asked:
have you ever written or spoken about
calling Scouts Scouts
rather than boys or kids?
Well, hey, Vin,
I can't recall ever really going into much depth
on the question.
I know that I sent this out
as a tweet a while back.
If you want your Scouts to act like Scouts,
call them Scouts.
If you call them kids,
they'll act like kids.
I think it is true.
I think you tend to get what you expect.
and if you want your Scouts
to act like Scouts
and to be Scouts.
I would avoid calling them anything else.
Gary Gomez works with
Boy Scout Troop in San Diego, California,
and he wrote in to ask:
I was curious as to what you think about
having prerequisites
for positions of responsibility, such as age
or number of years in Scouting, etc.
Should a Scout be required to be a patroller
before being allowed to run
for senior patroller?
I can see both pros and cons,
wondering what your experience is.
Well, Gary, I think
either way works
In my troop. in my troop,
we don't have prerequisites for this
and things seem to go fine.
Scouts make very good decisions.
They have prerequisites in their own minds
when they're voting for a patroller
or senior patroller.
Scouts ought to be reminded
about the seriousness of it
and when they take it seriously,
they'll make very good choices.
What I've found is, if we create
these kind of rules,
we can set up a whole list of prerequisites
that Scouts need to have
before they can run for patroller
or senior patroller.
as soon as the ink dries on those rules,
we're faced with a situation
that's an exception to the rule.
so I'm not saying that you can't have them.
what I'm saying is,
in my experience, you don't need them.
I am withholding the name
of the person who sent me this next email
for what will become obvious reasons.
I've been following your blog
and your opinion on all things scouting.
My son is 15,
a high school sophomore,
and has almost completed everything he needs
to become an Eagle Scout.
He's been an active youth leader and scout.
he's earned his religious emblems.
he's active in the OA.
he's been to two national jamborees.
he's been to Fillmont, Northern Tier,
and he's headed to Seabase
over Spring Break this year
and then back to Northern Tier this summer
with the OA program.
He's a former medal.
he's also in the international
baccalaureate program at school.
he loves scouting
and all it has to offer,
especially those high adventure opportunities.
our troop has recently formed
what they call a venture patrol,
but my son is a little put off
by the fact that he's been presented
with a venture patrol contract
and the contract has a number of stipulations.
one is that scouts have to be 14
and older, they have to be
15 and higher and they have to have
over 70% attendance
in the past six months.
they also must attend and participate
in 75% of the meetings, troop outing
and service projects,
and it says in the contract if their attendance is too low
or there are three-
quote- unexcused absences-
unquote- the scout master has a discretion
to take punitive action
towards them. it says they have to wear
the uniform correctly and set an example
in behavior. and set an example.
it says on camp out the venture patrol
won't be able to set up their camp
until the entire troop is set up.
that the venture patrol runs
the Sunday night campfire on every camp out.
that the venture patrol has got to be
the last ones to bed
and the first ones up in the morning.
and finally, it says that any
high adventure activities that the venture patrol
plans can't compete with the
regularly scheduled troop activities.
I looked at this contract with my son
and there are a lot of things in it
that don't sit well with either of us.
I assume it was created without
any youth input.
it seems more exclusionary,
designed to keep scouts out rather than
keep them engaged in the scouting program.
it all seems kind of heavy handed,
with punitive undertones on the adult side.
I would very much appreciate
any insight you might have about this.
wow,
well, every once in a while
it's just amazing how many different
ways we can find
to squelch the enthusiasm of scouts.
I'm going to be a little
snarky here, but I'll bet that
the adults that came up with this
contract are all men,
because women are usually quite a bit smarter
when it comes to this type of thing.
now, from what I read in this
email, here's a scout who would
do all the things on this contract
voluntarily,
but he's turned off by the idea of
somebody forcing him to do them
and who wouldn't be. frankly,
perhaps I can offer an explanation
of why this feels
and why this is so wrong.
it's
the first point of the scout law
and that is what
a scout is trustworthy.
the explicit message of
requiring a contract
from a scout is that
without a way to force you to do things,
we can't trust you
or respect your word.
now, in a business context,
or good, necessary tools
in scouting, I find them
downright offensive as well as
inimical to the entire foundation
of our work.
a scout is
trustworthy. you can't
reduce trustworthiness to a piece of paper
and, as any parent knows,
you're not going to force
a 15 year old to do anything
because he's put his name
on a contract. if you want to get
all legalistic about it,
minors can't sign contracts.
I know that a contract
like this isn't going to go to a court of law,
but that fact is kind of indicative
of how very wrong-headed this is.
contracts like this
don't change hearts
and minds or build
character. they actually undermine
this. now listen,
I know that the scouters who came up
with this idea are well
intentioned and I'm sure they have
good hearts, but they're setting
themselves up as
enforcers and bosses
rather than mentors and advisors.
they don't understand this
yet and they will only see it after
it fails to work for them and this
sort of thing almost inevitably backfires.
now, how can I be
so sure about this? I've done it
myself. I found that it was
a mistake. I stopped doing
it, and me and my scouts were
happier for it, I can tell you. so
I would sit down with your son and I would ask
him what he wants to do
and then help him make this happen.
if what he wants to do is get out
and do more adventurous things,
then he can be the one who gets everybody
moving. where does he want to go? what does he want
to do? if none of the adults in his
troop are willing to make this happen
for him, he can go looking for adults
that are helping scouts make this
happen now. naturally he's loyal
to his troop and to his fellow
scouts, but that loyalty
shouldn't restrict them from doing
great things. Scouts who see
this sort of spirit
and this kind of engagement and
excitement about scouting as
a threat to their program because,
oh my gosh, the scout might
plan something that conflicts with our
plans- they're just plain wrong
and they end up losing the
loyalty and interest of scouts,
like your son, because of it.
we do our best work as
scouts when we find a way
to make things happen for
scouts rather than trying to
control all the variables.
Andrew West is an assistant
scout master with troop 501
in Cleveland, Ohio and he writes
to ask this: what is the
ideal troop size? I've read that
Lord Baden Powell said a troop
size of 32 is ideal
because you end up with about 4
patrols of 8 boys. but I've
seen troops who are effective from
6 to over 100 scouts.
what would be the largest a troop
would be? instill, deliver the promise of scouting
and ensure that every scout gets
the best possible experience.
our troop has experienced tremendous
growth. if we look into the future-
maybe 2 or 3 years- we could easily
well be north of 100 scouts.
myself and other adults are asking
ourselves: how do we know
if we're getting too big? I know
there's no hard or fast rules or a
specific number, but any thoughts on
this topic was appreciated. I
appreciate all you do and your very
well know nonsense views on scouting.
well, Andrew, thank you so much
for getting in touch.
here's the thing: scouting
does have a scale. for instance,
we know patrols work best
when they number between 6 and 10,
but the size of troops is really an
open question. what's really
important is patrols. the patrol
is the scale of scouting.
Baden Powell frequently emphasize
that a scout should never feel
as though he's just member of
a great, vast herd of scouts.
any scout should know
and work with his patrol
and feel that he's known and appreciated
in his patrol and in his troop.
youth leaders also need to be able to
work and plan at a scale
that's realizable for them.
some big troops pull this off
very well and I think they make this
happen because they emphasize patrols,
youth leadership
and then they make sure that each
individual scout gets the attention
they deserve. the temptation, however,
with a big troop is to manage
scouts and herds rather than
individuals or patrols.
this herd approach is really very pragmatic
and many troops, large and small,
tend to do things that way
because it's easier and there's a scale
at which youth leaders are
very good and you get too far
beyond that scale and things
start to erode a little bit.
if a troop runs on the herd plan,
youth leaders are usually
marginalized and adults are doing most
of the work. I will tell you that our
troop has hovered at around 30
for all the time I've been involved.
I have to do some pretty high
stepings as a scout master to keep up
with conferences and to work
with youth leaders. I know
some scout masters are able to make
this happen with a troop of 60 or 100,
but I got to tell you it would be beyond
me. even so, I think
the size of a troop is immaterial so
long as they are operating the patrol system,
assuring there's plenty of opportunity
for developing youth leadership
and paying individual attention
to their scouts. as you say,
there's no right or wrong answers,
but there are sound principles
by which we can arrive at a conclusion.
here's another anonymous
email. I have a vexing problem.
I have a scout who, from what I've
heard him passing from the other scouts,
will not be welcome in any patrol.
he's been diagnosed with
Asperger's syndrome and finds it
difficult to sit. still, he can
be disruptive and he doesn't stay on
task. his parents do keep an eye
on him during meetings and outings, though
how do I advise my patrol leaders
counsel about working with the scout
and making sure that he is included in
a patrol? well, I would sit down
with your patrol leaders counsel and I would
ask them some questions. first
question I would ask is: do you think
that any boy, regardless
of whether he has any limitations
or difficulties, should be welcome
in our troop? I would be
interested in what their answers are
and I would be interested in
discussing this with them in the context
of the scout oath and law. I would
also ask them if they knew of any
scouts in our troop at present
who they feel may have issues
that would make it difficult
for them to participate or to
join in sometimes- and they are
very likely going to know exactly
what you're talking about and come up
with the name of the scout you mentioned-
then I would start asking them some questions
about this scouts behavior.
do you think that he
is misbehaving intentionally?
I mean, that's a question that they may not
have considered themselves, and that
question and their answers
can lead you into a conversation about
differences. I would tell
the patrol leaders counsel
that we all feel individually
that we are the outside, or
sometimes we feel like people don't
understand or appreciate us,
and I would ask them if any of them have ever
felt that way and how
that feels. and then I would ask
them if they would ever intentionally
try to make somebody
feel as though they were an outsider
or they weren't understood
or appreciated. scouts get this.
they know that they promise to be
friendly, helpful and kind.
that's something we usually think
about as individuals, but
can they tell you
how they do that as a group
of scouts? can they be
helpful, friendly and kind?
as a patrol leaders counsel, you may
have a story about how you overcame
first impressions in the frustration
of dealing with somebody who had
limitations over which they had no control.
you can share that story
and tell the scouts that it took a lot of work
to understand what was going on at first,
but you applied the scout law
to the situation and you're glad
you made the effort. maybe you can recall
an instance in your youth where you failed
to do this, because I know I can
share the regrets you feel
and tell your scouts how you would
like to have the chance to go back
in time and make that right,
but you can't. now the message
is clear. no, scout is a burden,
he's your brother scout,
and we never let our brother scout down.
it can take some extra effort and patience
on our part, but that's why we're scouts.
in the end you'll find that all
the effort was worth it, because
not only have you helped someone,
but you also earned a new friend.
I'm going to withhold the name
in this next email too.
could you offer your thoughts
on dealing with brothers in a troop setting?
my senior patrol leader has a younger brother.
I've often told him he needs to treat
his younger brother as he would any other scout,
but despite my request,
he still treats him differently.
sometimes he's belittling or difficult
with his younger brother.
well, when it comes to any family relationship-
and that's brother to brother
to children or husband and wife-
there needs to be some straight talk
that draws a line between family roles
and scouting roles.
now, I'm not suggesting that family roles
are less important than scouting roles,
but there needs to be
a dividing line.
when mom is in her scout master role,
she's not mom anymore
and her son is not a son.
her son is a scout.
when the older brother is a senior patrol leader,
he's not an older brother anymore.
the older patrol leader and his younger brother
is a scout.
there's a dividing line.
outside of scouts, we have one role.
in scouts, we have another role.
what I'm saying is
that any family relationship
needs some specific attention
and discussion from both parties,
who agree that there's a difference
in the roles that they have
depending on whether they're in scouts
or out of scouts.
sometimes a trusted mediator
or maybe the parent of these brothers
will be beneficial in helping
people sort this out.
and to wind things up,
I have two emails,
both anonymous, but they basically have
the same answer.
the first one says this:
this summer our troop is going on a long trip,
so we're chartering a bus.
the bus charter saves adults
an entire vacation day
for this trip, since we're going to be able to
drive through the night.
the other adult wants to drive himself
with a couple of other adults
who don't really feel like they want to ride on the bus.
my objection to this
is that this is a group trip
and if they aren't with the group,
they somehow become special.
the other adults who are going to be asking themselves:
if these guys get to drive,
why can't I drive?
so hold that in your mind for a moment
and let me read this other email.
this weekend our troop went on a camp
out about four hours away
from our departure. they were going to drive together
in the same car
and take three of our new scouts
and friends earlier.
we asked them not to do that
and to leave with everybody else,
so the group would be traveling together,
but they ignored us and they went on their own.
that same group
left an hour early when we were getting ready to go.
they just got in their cars
and drove home.
they didn't help break camp or even let us know
they were leaving.
both of those situations.
and let's begin by saying: scout camping trips
are for scouts
and they go camping together in patrols.
scout camping trips are not for adults
and they're not for families.
we aren't going camping because
it's a recreational activity
open to everybody who wants to tag along.
we're going camping with some very
specific goals in mind.
the patrolling camp
is the whole reason we're doing this in the first place.
we meet to prepare for camping.
we go camping so patrols
can work together and grow as scouts.
everything else about it:
the places that we go,
the things that we do when we get there,
the things that the scouts learn.
that's kind of fringe benefits on top of the fact
that patrols are going camping.
that's the real heart of what we do.
not every parent is going to understand this,
so we need to tell them
that there are some trips when parents are invited,
but otherwise
adult attendance on camping trips
is included to registered and trained leaders.
now, before I go any further,
let me remind you
that what you're hearing is my opinion.
it is not official policy
from any scouting organization.
this is just the way that I do things.
if it makes sense to you,
fine. if it doesn't make sense to you,
fine. but when I have
a new adult who is going on their first
trip with our scouts,
I take them aside and I explain
what they can and cannot do
and I ask them to follow my lead.
absolutely
now, the scout master obviously
advises scouts and he works with them
with an open hand. he's their mentor
and advisor and counselor.
but when it comes to adults,
the scout master leads adults.
they do what the scout master says.
when the scout master says it.
if adults don't like this,
they can stay at home.
this analogy might help you. the scouts are the players,
the scout master is the head coach,
they're registered in trained adults.
our assistant coaches
and parents are spectators
and they're going to be spectators
and you have trained them to play the game
properly. as for travel arrangements
and things like that,
if we accept the principles that I've
discussed thus far,
it should be understood that everybody travels
together. it's not an option
and just from a practical standpoint,
we're going to have a lot of people arriving
at different times
who disappear, leaving the work to all those
who stay behind.
so, once again, scout camping trips are for scouts
and they go camping together
in patrols.
our trips aren't for adults to go on some
wonderful recreational activity,
it's not for families to have some recreational weekend
and they're not open
to just anybody who wants to tag along.
we're going camping
with some very specific goals in mind
and everything else is kind of a fringe benefit.
patrols- going camping
is the real heart of what we do.
well, that was a
pile of email, questions and answers.
if you have a question for me,
you can get in touch and you're going to find out
how to do that in just a moment.
well, thanks for listening to this
212th edition
of the scoutmaster podcast.
here's how to get in touch.
read the blog at scoutmastercgcom.
you can also subscribe to receive
updates to the blog by email.
you can get the scoutmastercg app
on google play or in the iTunes store.
the app will give you
access to all of our blog posts
and all of our podcasts, including the
podcast archive.
there's some other resources and things in the app
that you might find useful. once again,
it's available on google play
or in the iTunes app store.
look for the scoutmastercg app.
you can get in
on what we do at scoutmastercgcom
through the vast
panorama of social media outlets.
join the 4900 folks
who like scoutmaster blog on facebook.
tweet along with the chorus of
950 tweeters on twitter.
pin the pultritudinous pictures
proffered publicly
with 1200 other prolific pinners
on Pinterest.
watch us, if you dare,
at scoutmastercg on youtube.
or join the 400 odd folks
exclusive scoutmastercg circle
on google plus.
now, if you can't face facebook,
if twitter makes you better,
if you have no interest in Pinterest,
if you don't put the? u in youtube,
if you are a minus when it comes to google plus,
well, that's okay. bunkie,
zoom into the late 90s
and send me an email.
you can get in touch with me,
clarkgreen, with your comments and questions
and wild ideas
by emailing.
that's c-l-a-r-k-e
at
scoutmastercgcom.
the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America
or any other scouting organization for that matter.
no, it is just me
talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
speaking of fun, here's our founder,
Mr Baden Powell.
sir robert,
good luck to you and good camping,
why? thank you, sir,
until next time, everyone.